what's going on guys national master james kante
the third here with chess.com and today we have
the top five swindles swindles guys i'm sure
you've been there before maybe you've swindled
a game of two or two in your life but this is
the top five swindles from some of the best in
the speed chess championships in this first game
we have alexander grishik vs magnus carlsen this
was back in 2017 yes 2017 guys so let's see what
happens white actually just played queen e3 so
alexander grisham just played queen e3 in this
weird position guys a lot going on back rank
is covered by black maybe even the light squares
could be a problem for white here but also there's
like checks and like maybe even some type of mates
like some type of you know 97s and queen g5s and
mates there's there's stuff going on this is a
powerful position here after queen e3 this is what
magnus does magnus just plays queen d7 what queen
d7 it's a very rare blunder at this level guys but
it's a blunder queen d7 what happens after queen
d7 what would you play here fight to move guys
queen d7 is a blunder here it is knight f6 very
simple thanks for the queen i'm sure alexander
grishik was like what am i am i being tricked i
mean what is this knight f6 and here it is the
queen falls guys the queen falls and then he
follows up this is not even the swindle part
it looks like black's just lost right maybe some
counter play especially with some checks and like
things can happen the rook's on the back rank so
it is pretty scary still here we go he says f4
so i'm just going to move my king to f2 actually
after this but here is the swindling part guys now
the best move actually let's go back here queen
to d3 is actually the best move is what they call
eyeballing shout out to yasser shiron is
what he would say here queen to d3 eyeballing
the d7 and the g6 square as well this is a
nasty move here and then after we have a bishop
c6 bishop d5 capture capture and then um white's
really playing for two results here so uh either
winning or drawing now going back here he actually
played f4 in this position after bishop takes
grisham chose f4 leading us into rookie eight now
there's all kind of damage that's about to happen
to white's position here so after rook two eight
he's in a lot of trouble here actually so he just
gives it back he just says all right cool you know
what hey i'll give you your queen back let's see
what we can do here but look at this position now
guys what a swindle i lost my queen i got it back
now can i win this game well let's see rook b4
king g7 king f2 a5 we're just going to push to
pass pawn rook b8 and bishop c6 a lot of moves
here so we're going to fast forward some rook b6
uh we're k3 here bishop d1 we're going to fast
forward some moves here guys pawn takes and rook
g1 we're just we're just maneuvering that's that's
kind of what they're doing maneuvering trying to
pro make some weaknesses here i also put some
threats on the board here as much as we can so
king d4 steps off of it you take mine i take yours
bishop b7 you take mine i take yours and now guys
whoa what happened here i'm up two pawns in an
end game what i was down a queen though or down
the exchange for the queen now i'm actually
in the position to win this game says magnus
now after rook here we're gonna sack our rook on
this all day and every day in any way so let's see
what happens we push some pawns here pawns get
pushed king walks up a little bit we capture i
queen view queen but with check now he moves out
of the way and then the rest honestly is technique
from here these are hard end games but especially
with this past pawn here black has a huge chance
of winning this game so after a few checks or a
lot of checks actually a lot of checking being
done king moves around does what he has to do then
we go back to the back rank and go here and then
he resigns that was it he resigned like
right here he just resigned right here
because there's no way to stop queen g6 jack
also queen e7 check if you check me anywhere
i'm gonna go queen e7 and this is queening
easily i mean this is elementary uh in game
from here guys what a swindle actually looking
back at that guys looking back at that right here
just going back to it we lost our queen this is
why you don't give up we lost our queen magnus
says yeah i lost it did he resign no he kept
playing he kept playing on f4 rookie eight wow
i get my queen back because there's mating threats
and all kind of nasty things happening after check
here i mean even if you move your queen like
queen c5 to stop the check that's checkmate or
almost it actually had to block with the queen on
f2 but then bishop c6 oh my goodness let's just
oh my goodness that's just too many things going
on here so he just he just said forget it let's
just take it and then we go into a winning
end game what a swindle guys this will swindle
number one now let's move on to swindle number
two and here we are with swindle number two
this is york meyer with the white pieces versus
sergey karyakin with the black pieces in 2017.
so let's see what happened here guys in this
position actually queen f7 was the last move
played by sergey now sergey is under some pressure
here guys this looks kind of weird looking
this pawn's hanging we got a pass pawn here i mean
there's a lot going on even the bishop is aiming
on this side of the board but we do have some
compensation with the pass pawn in the center
but not realistically because it can always be
stopped here so it's kind of just like dynamic
to say the least here now here's what happens
immediately york meyer just plays rook takes b6
and we're like hey we're just going to take the
pawn pretty simple here there should be nothing
but there actually is something here black to move
guys what do you actually do here in this position
here we go sergey actually just played rook to d1
check rook d1 check if you take my rook i'm going
to take your queen so this is automatic
king f2 is forced and then knight to d3
wow now we're in a driver's seat now we're picking
up some material after you just snapped this pawn
here thinking you were winning well think again
king to g3 knight takes c1 queen to c6 just
stepping out of the way actually also hitting his
rook as well so we move our rook to f8 just bring
everything to this side of the board where your
king is now after bishop takes c1 queen takes f5
a5 and then e4 and now this is very scary i mean
there's a check here pawn takes is coming queen
g6 check looks and it looks pretty nice too
you have a lot of moves here and you're also
threatening to take this just in case a6 was
played and then e takes f3 and circuit karaoke
actually won this game right here right here he
won the game york meyer just resigned and honestly
it is uh it's just over here but there's a lot of
things that you can do from this position queen
g6 is especially after queen takes f3 and if pawn
takes we may even have rook g1 check in some cases
maybe queen g6 first and then queen to g oh my
goodness it's just there's so much going on guys
there's so much going on but the swindle happened
back here after queen f7 queen c4 queen f7
we had the block and white's giving some pressure
to black here i mean if you look at this position
even now if queen f7 wasn't to move where you
kind of need need that to happen but it's not
the easiest position to play here as black
yeah you are hitting this pawn but this is
hanging this is hanging the rooks are coordinated
nicely the bishop's looking good the rook's kind
of misplaced to be honest it looks kind of weird
here on the d5 square so queen f7 we defend it and
then man there's our chance we take it every time
we see our chance rook d1 king f2 93 and the rest
is history nice swindle here by sergey karyakin to
go on and win this game and now we're gonna move
on to swindle number three now with swindle number
three this one is so awesome guys this is actually
one that you may even see in your own games and
a concept that you should definitely remember
this game is actually anishkiri versus wesley so
with the black pieces back in 2017 let's actually
see what's going on here black is about to queen
wesley so is trying to clean one of these pawns as
quickly as possible especially this one's going to
queen because this one can't yet because of this
and you can't actually push this pawn because
the the this is this is here it just doesn't
seem right here you also have like maybe checks
and takes and you're able to hold as black here
while you're also able to try to queen this pawn
at the same time but here's what anish giri did
anish geary looked around the board and understood
all of his resources and he plays rook to g3 now
the game should be drawn but he actually sets a
very clever trap here what do you think he's doing
well wesley so says b3 i don't know what you're
doing i have i don't understand i don't understand
and after b3 guys what do you actually do now
here's what is what was supposed to happen is
actually bishop to b5 and after rook takes
the bishop to c4 because this pawn is not
really promoting and the king has to step off we
can also step up and we have a pawn of our own
so there's too many things this should be drawn
but actually that was not to move wesley so
actually chose b3 trying to queen in this position
what do you do now anish geary what do you do now
like to move here it is guys here it is swindu
f7 f7 i don't care what you do you're gonna lose
this game now there is checkmate on the back ring
and if we try check well we take it and then we
come and grab this pawn with our king and this one
with our rook and then it's king rick versus king
very simple easy win there guys what a swindle
i mean it's so like such a deadly move but so
quiet at the same time rick to g3 nothing so he
plays b3 wesley cells like ah i'm gonna queen
and then f7 and he's like i'm not gonna queen
anything and the game is over on the spot what
a swindle congratulations to anishgiri for that
one that was really nice guys now let's move on to
swindle number four now for swindle number four we
have yani pomniacci versus levon nickleronion in
2017 guys let's check this out this is a roy lopez
morphe defense cozio defense actually and here's
what happened so lebron ironian actually first
off his kings in the center so let's see what
happens here this is a wild game guys and watch
the sequence of moves that's about to happen
knight takes d4 first off of course we can't take
just because uh you know obvious reasons our queen
is just hanging so he plays bishop b4 not only
hitting the rook but also defending f3 as well
okay rook moves out of the way and here we go guys
are you ready for this knight takes d4 i don't
even care that you're taking my queen i don't care
says yan prominent now the queen sack is unsound
in a way but of course even at the high level
here you have to be extremely accurate and it is
definitely scary so now let's see what happens
what's his intention did we just take back on d1
actually no in between moves this is a knight to
c6 beautiful move here actually hitting the queen
and the knight at the same time your opponent will
be so unexpected when he sees this on the board
now bishop takes c3 was the wrong move actually
here wrong move bishop takes c3 uh actually knight
takes c6 was the best way to play believe it or
not and after bishop takes king f8 rook takes in
queen f6 bishop to d7 rook d8 bishop takes c7 rook
takes rook takes and then king ga now this is the
refutation of it but of course there's still
some complex to it and some complexity to it but
black is objectively just better um here but
it is it's gonna be a fight it is gonna be a
fight but this is the way that he should have
proceeded here but actually he took on c3 and
after bishop takes pawn takes so now we actually
have the bishop pair on top of the queen set
so after knight takes c1 c6 bishop takes king f8
rook takes and then queen to f6 now let's see what
happens here guys let's look at the position we
got two rooks actually kind of one because this
one's not doing anything the king is unsafe we got
bishop swiping the board and two rooks i mean this
is definitely some compensation here so bishop
to d7 threatening the rook after rook d8 ouch
and there we are with the skewer and that
is the problem with the bishop takes c3 move
because with it without bishop take c3 the skewer
wouldn't be allowed and now we would be able to
keep some material on the board now this is enough
to win here after bishop takes h8 f6 and then h4
c5 and then rook to d5 guys king to g8 bishop
check and then bishop back to d7 now here watch
this best move here bishop c6 beautiful move
beautiful move because now i'm going to take
and then check on the back rank if you of course
defend your rook now if he takes the bishop
which he does then we take and h5 cut the king off
make sure he's stuck in here there's a mate threat
on the board king f7 he comes around the back way
here check double the rooks because we have to
queen here to d5 rook d7 game's over swindle
swin duel swindle guys what a swindle okay man
he was not hey this queen sack is not supposed
to work and he's done it before too this is not
the first time he's ever done this queen site
not that it's not supposed to work but it's
hard finding the refutation to it because we're
not computers so now after this bishop takes d1
knight c6 beautiful beautiful and play here bishop
d7 bishop b5 now we take the other rook and then
we need to cut some things off okay bring the
check in bring the bishop back around bishop
to c6 here and the game is over very soon yani
pamniacci was a monster for this swindle here and
after rook here the game's over because we have
a check mate here and a checkmate here and if you
take of course obvious reasons you just lose it's
rook versus everything else and bringing the queen
to g8 is checkmate bringing a queen here it's it
just doesn't work everything's losing so of course
uh yanipaniachi wins in this position right here
guys that was swindle number four and now let's
move on to the final swindle of today and here we
go guys the last swindle of today here we are guys
this is magnus carlson versus wesley so with the
black pieces back in 2017 let's actually see what
happened here this started as already ended up
in some kind of kings indian attack and b5 was
just played by wesley cell so magnus says okay
we're going to capture then capture back and then
we take on a a and then take on a8 honestly guys
looks objectively drawn there is some play there
is some play from both sides here especially a
queen side play here this pawn is very weak and
also white just has kind of some dynamicism in the
center maybe we can break this down play some c4
and just kind of see what happens here white's not
hoping for a lot here but we are we still have to
play on so after knight to e3 rook to d8 and then
after knight takes d5 the game is just drawn after
he takes d5 and uh of course you have to still
play on you got to be accurate you still have to
you know work for this draw but it's not that easy
actually e takes d5 should be the best move but
here's what wesley so chose to he does rick takes
d5 it takes d5 seems like a simple move right
seems like everything's fine or is it guys or
is it what would you play in this position if
you were magnus here what would you play with
white here it is guys here it is queen takes d5
whoa magnus carlsen wins by resignation although
the game should have been drawn after he takes d5
because now after pawn takes rook check
bishop f8 and bishop to h6 very nice way
to finish off a win here now of course this is a
winning end game and he did go on to win this game
actually but it was a draw and actually uh it was
a draw and wesley cell just resigned queen takes
d5 he was like ah oh my goodness the game should
be a draw you know actually after uh he takes d5
rookie a bishop f8 bishop h6 and uh he win he won
this game from the resignation to be honest but uh
queen takes d5 he takes d5 it's just a draw but
the queen sacrifice was so stunning that he just
resigned before he got here that's what happened
sometimes sometimes you ever seen that move or you
ever played that move on the board and you've
seen it happen and they're like oh my goodness
i can't believe i missed that and it's actually
a draw i've been there many times i'm sure you
probably have before especially after analyzing
your game perfect example here from two monsters
actually queen takes d5 should be just a draw
because of course he takes you know rook check
now of course you can uh there is some some play
here you have some things to do takes takes and
this should be a draw but of course you know the
king is a little bit closer we could also maybe
try to work some things in but objectively just
kind of drawing three versus three right three
versus three this was the top five swindles of the
speed chess championship guys i hope you enjoyed
today's video and i'm national master james canty
the third and i'll see you guys on the next video